if you're looking for ways to make every
second count not overthink things and
prioritize then this video is for you
you don't achieve worthwhile goals
quickly or easily they take time it's
pretty easy sometimes to to feel beaten
when you're faced with all those issues
and all those problems and they all hit
you at the same time the more you sit
here and you're planning the less we
know what's going on out there the
things are happening they're changing
they're evolving the enemy is
maneuvering there's developments on the
battlefield or in the marketplace and
you don't even know because you're
sitting in the planning space need
motivation watch a top 10 with belief
nation what's up it's Evan my 1 word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out into the world
so let's take your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew on today's lessons from a
man who went from being a Navy SEALs
commander and receiving the Silver Star
and Bronze Star for his service to now
being an influential author and
podcaster he's jakka willing and here's
my take on his top 10 rules of success
vol 2
enjoy
I recognize half rule number one make
every second count
rome wasn't built in a day we all know
that everyone's hears that but rome also
didn't fall apart overnight either it
took hundreds of years for Rome to reach
its peak but it also took time hundreds
of years for Rome to decay and fall
apart and that is representative of life
because you don't achieve worthwhile
goals quickly or easily they take time
they take struggle they take relentless
pursuit day in and day out that's what
it takes but also things don't usually
fall apart quickly either at least at
first it's it's a slow process a little
slip here a little setback over there a
little wearing down of discipline and
will over time that's the thing success
and failure are generally slow processes
either slowly building things up or
gradually tearing them down
and that's why I say you've got to pay
attention you have to watch you have to
watch every single second because those
seconds they turn into minutes then
minutes turn into hours and hours turn
into days and days turn in to years and
so that second that second that just
went by that counted then so did that
second and so did that one and in those
precious seconds you are either building
or you're decaying you were either
gaining ground or you were losing ground
in that second and in every second
every second counts
so make every second count
first off gotta love Jocko the intensity
that he always brings every single
message just makes you feel the
importance that he feels I love this
clip I think it's a fantastic message I
want to have on my office door a big
sign that says make today count so every
time I walk in the office I see that so
this is my favorite one so far but let's
see what we got with rule number two
take ownership when a team takes
ownership of its problems the problems
get solved and that is true on the
battlefield it is true in business and
it is true in life so I say take
ownership take extreme ownership don't
make excuses don't blame any other
person or any other thing get control of
your ego don't hide your delicate pride
from the truth take ownership of
everything in your world the good and
the bad take ownership of your mistakes
take ownership of your shortfalls take
ownership of your problems and then take
ownership of the solutions that will get
those problems solved take ownership of
your mission take ownership of your job
of your team of your future and take
ownership of your life and lead lead
lead yourself and your team and the
people in your life lead them all the
victory main another fantastic message
back to back this is another one I
firmly believe in that the reason why
you are where you are is because of you
and when you take ownership and stop
blaming the government of your family
your upbringing that's when you start to
make change
Jaakko man he's bringing the goods real
one and two are so good I love it I love
it so far let's keep it going rule
number three cast out the lies the
chronic excuse maker how do you stop
making excuses this is actually pretty
simple and I said it the other day and
you have to realize you have to know you
have to accept that all your excuses are
lies their lies all of them think about
the things that you tell yourself the
lies you used to rationalize taking the
easy road taking the easy road and
leaving discipline behind think about
them you don't have time that's a lie
you don't have support that's a lie you
don't have the equipment or the gear
lies you don't you don't know the best
way who cares that's a lie or you're too
old or you're too young of course you're
too old or too young lie and there's
you're too busy sure you are that's high
and you're too tired or you're too sore
or you're just plain not feeling it lies
lies lies and the list goes on
and on and on then it doesn't stop if
you don't make it stop so recognize
[Music]
recognize the excuses are not valid
they aren't they're trumped-up they're
conjured up they're fabricated they're
lies and how do you stop the lies you
stop the lies with the truth the truth
the truth will set you free the truth
will stand and the truth will deliver
you from procrastination and laziness
and the downward spiral that comes with
a lack of discipline so don't believe
the lies believe the truth and the truth
is you have time you have the skill you
have the knowledge and the support and
the willpower and the discipline to get
it done so cast out the lies burn them
down and listen to the truth and live
the truth and go out and get it done
another fantastic one junko really
delivering on this one ties in really
well with rule number two take ownership
you got to take ownership and then cast
out the lies cast out the excuses that
you have for the reasons why you're not
more successful I love it it's hard to
pick my favorite this is great let's
keep it going though rule number four
stop looking for shortcuts I don't
really like those words self-help or
self management or self-improvement I
don't really like what those words have
come to mean these days because there's
a lot of people out there that are
constantly trying to improve themselves
by looking for the
change the one change right the one
change in their life that's gonna make
their dreams come true and even worse on
top of that there's a lot of people out
there a lot of self-help gurus and these
hyperactive motivational speakers and
these other self-appointed modern Zen
yoga warriors that they're trying to
sell the one thing they're trying to
sell the nine steps or the enlightened
path that's gonna allow you to unlock
all of your human potential and fulfill
the dreams so you can live the life that
you've you've always wanted to live
now I'm no guru and I definitely don't
claim to be I'm just a man but I will
tell you this it isn't one thing and it
isn't ten things and it isn't a hundred
things
it isn't a quick path and there are no
shortcuts the meditation won't get you
there and neither will a miracle drug or
an organic supplement or some superfood
getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or all one change that you need to make
getting better is a campaign it's a
campaign it's a daily a weekly it's an
hourly fight an incessant fight that
doesn't stop against weakness and
against temptation and against laziness
it's a campaign of discipline the
campaign of hard work and dedication
it's waking up early and going to bed
late and grinding out every second in
between every single day so you want to
get better you want to self-improve stop
looking for a shortcut and go find your
alarm clock and find your disk
and find your guts and your passion and
your drive and find it you will and then
and then you will find your freedom so I
like this clip I think of it as
embracing the end I think yes you need
to wake up yes you need to be
disciplined yes you need to go in your
campaign yes you need to decide that
you're gonna be responsible for your
life and you want to look for the
fastest way to do it you know I'm a huge
believer in modeling success that's why
I have these top ten rules videos and my
channel really I think you can learn
from the people who've come before you
and that can help shortcut your path to
get there but it's not just gonna be
handed to you yourself the wake up
really still to do the work you still
gotta grind it out you still have to get
up every day and do something so this
one I get where he's going with it I
like it I like the first three better
but hopefully you can still take this
one with that grain of salt too and just
because you're looking for shortcuts it
doesn't mean you're not gonna stop
working hard to get your dreams to have
let's go to rule number five prioritize
and execute when things go wrong they
always seem to happen at once and they
just compound on top of each other and
it's it's pretty easy sometimes to to
feel beaten when you're faced with all
those issues and all those problems and
they all hit you at the same time but
let me tell you that that doesn't mean
give up in fact it means the opposite it
means it's time for you to fight harder
to dig in means it's time for you to go
on the warpath and that starts with one
of the fundamental laws of combat
leadership prioritize and execute what's
the biggest problem what's causing the
most stress family okay
sit them down explain where you are at
the blunts be upfront and then give them
the simple plan of how you're gonna get
things back on track don't sugarcoat it
you give it to him straight next you've
got some some late payments call those
creditors up explain to them what's
going on set up some kind of a low of a
minimum payment plan so you can start
making some progress and get them off
your back and then you got your job
right you're falling behind at work
okay talk to your boss face it tell him
that you're gonna step up your game tell
him you're gonna be at work early you're
gonna be at work late you're gonna be at
work during lunch you're gonna be
wherever you need to be whenever he
needs you to be there tell him you're
gonna get after it and tell them that
you're a hundred percent committed to
supporting him and the company and the
mission and then you get started
the thing I take from this is perfection
is the enemy of execution a lot of times
you want to have the perfect plan the
perfect conversation the perfect outline
the perfect business proposal and
because you wanted to be perfect you
don't do anything so just make a list of
the things you need to do and then just
start doing it because some action even
if it's not perfect action gets you
closer to your goals than just sitting
on your bed or sitting on your couch
with the dream and never do anything
about it let's go to rule number six
hold the line I keep getting asked this
type of question how do I get discipline
or how do I want discipline or how do I
maintain discipline and the answer it's
it's a simple answer but obviously it's
not easy
and there's all kinds of little tricks
and methods that people talk about and
you know they have some merit
you know maybe they do work these these
things you know do the little things
people say and wake up early I say that
and write things down and take cold
showers
and tell everyone what you're going to
do so broadcast it and make promises or
or make bets with with your friends of
something that you don't want to lose
and those things those ideas they're
cool I'm sure they're gonna have some
impact and if they work for you that's
that's awesome but but the fact of the
matter is that the reason discipline is
hard to maintain is because it is hard
to maintain that's what makes discipline
hard it's hard and if you hear me claim
that discipline is easy for me then
straight up that's just my ego talking
that's what that is
because I'm unfortunately just as human
as everyone else and it is work to
maintain the discipline that's what it
is work holding the line maintaining the
standard giving no slack none that's the
discipline that's the discipline and it
is hard and if there's one thing I would
say that does make it easier it's to
envision what it feels like when you're
done what it feels like after you've
worked out or you've held the line on
your food intake or you've pushed
through some monotonous project that you
have to do and although
things when they're done that they feel
good and contrary to that envision what
you will feel like later when you let
the discipline slack you know the
feeling feeling weak and defeated and
you know that you're falling behind so
get to know those two different types of
feelings and ask yourself which one you
want to feel in ten minutes or in a half
an hour when when the thing is done when
the discipline has Blin implemented
remember what that feels like and then
remember that those minutes and those
hours they turn into weeks and months
and years and holding the line in those
political minutes will put you in an
infinitely better place physically and
mentally if you maintain the discipline
I really like the idea of imagining what
you'll feel like if you maintain the
discipline if you accomplish your goal
what that feeling is gonna feel like as
opposed to the feeling when you don't do
it and how weak you feel you let
yourself down again Tony Robbins has a
similar mantra or similar saying and so
I'm gonna think about that I think if I
can apply that more write down daily
goals but the idea of feeling what that
feels like when I accomplished them
something to think on thank you Jocko
for the bit of advice let's go to rule
number seven do not overthink things
tactics to flank flesh shift a ferocious
analyzer from paralysis to go meaning
what someone over things the landing and
planning and planning and planning well
there's a couple things here if the
person is above you or below you in the
chain of command
so if they're below you in the chain of
command you you know you explain to them
you say look we don't need perfection
we're not gonna have 100% solution we
don't have 100% of the information
that's a good enough solution we need to
move forward let's execute and you know
what I'll take her this thing's gonna
walk wrong don't worry about it I'll
take responsibility for it I'm not gonna
blame you which is what you're gonna do
anyways as a good leader so that's what
you can do for you there below you in
the chain of command if they're above
you in the chain of command guess what
same thing you gonna tell the same thing
like a boss we don't need perfection
here look boss we're not gonna get all
the information we need we're not gonna
get a hundred percent solution we got a
90 percent solution and let's go for it
and if things do go wrong you can blame
me I don't care so boom the weather that
are above your you know below you the
chain of command you might change your
tact or your verbage a little bit but
it's the same same overall concept you
got to get them to understand that we
don't need perfection we need to move
forward and the other thing is you
explain the cost of not moving the cost
of staying still the cost of being
reactive instead of proactive in
basically the cost of not being
aggressive because that's what we're
talking about is a lack of aggression
and so what does that look like well you
explain to them that the longer we sit
the better position the enemy gets into
the longer we wait the less we know
about what is actually happening think
about that one the more you sit here and
you're planning the less we know what's
going on out there the things are
happening they're changing they're
evolving the enemy is maneuvering
there's developments on the battlefield
or in the marketplace and you don't even
know because you're sitting in the
planning space hmm the longer we wait
the less time we have to recover if
something does go wrong mmm so if we sit
here and plan for 47 days and on the
40th day we set out we start to execute
something goes wrong we're not gonna
make the 50 day markers we will spend
all that time planning so the longer
that you're sitting around the last time
you have to recover and adapt and adjust
and the longer that you wait while
you're doing planning the less relevant
your plan actually becomes so that's
what you need to make people understand
so I'm a recovering perfectionist when I
was 22 I lost
on the sale of my business and our
competitor was bought for forty million
dollars instead of me because I was
waiting and waiting and waiting and
trying to make the perfect plan the
perfect plan the perfect plan and then I
realized I just lost a 40 million dollar
shield because I was trying to make the
perfect plane and it's still hard
sometimes they let go the perfectionism
but you just gotta go when you have an
idea understand I won't be perfect
expect to suck at the beginning and just
go and do something and learn and see if
you like it and see if you want to keep
doing it or not you can't think your way
into your passion you can't think your
way into achieving your goal you have to
actually get out there and do so stop
over complicating things stop trying to
make everything perfect you strive for
it but I understand you'll never get
there and just get out there and do
let's go to rule number eight stay on
the warpath those days when I'm tired or
worn out or just basically sick of the
grind well what do I do on those days I
go anyways I get it done even if I'm
just going through the motions I go
through the motions I don't really want
to work out I work out I really don't
want to hammer on a project I hammer on
the project don't really want to get up
and get out of bed yeah I get up and get
out of bed now these could be signals
that you need some time off and those
signals might be right they could be
correct but don't take today off not
today wait until tomorrow don't don't
give in to the immediate gratification
that is whispering in your ear shut that
down do not listen to that little voice
instead go through the motions lift the
weights
print the he'll work on the project get
out of bed now as an overall rule I do
not like procrastination you need to get
things done but if you are going to rest
that is one thing that you should
procrastinate on that's the one thing I
want you to pull it off until tomorrow
and if when tomorrow comes you still
feel like you need to rest or you need
to take a break then okay take it but
the chances are you won't you won't need
that rest chances are you will realize
that the desire to rest was just
weakness it was just the desire to take
the path of least resistance that
downhill path the easy path and by
simply going through the motions you
overcame that path and you stayed on the
righteous path the discipline path
you're stayed on the war path which is
right where you know but you belong
I love the specific tactic around
procrastinating on rest so if you feel
like giving yourself a break you feel
like taking a day off wait until
tomorrow I like that idea I'm gonna see
how I can apply it to my life the other
thing about just getting up and doing
the work is sometimes you should check
the box I think for me for working out
if I don't feel like it if I'm sick if
I'm really stretched on time and I don't
have the time to do the 30 minutes a
bike in the morning I'll still do 25
push-ups 30 push-ups 35 push-ups in the
morning just something that takes 30
seconds to do it doesn't take a lot of
time but it allows me to go through the
motions of at least doing a mini workout
instead of not having that box check for
the day and I find that that keeps
momentum going so tomorrow I'm back on
the bike doing it too so maybe yeah
extra strategy for you guys but I love
that tip from Jacque
moving on the rule number nine do the
right thing you know for me character is
not a very complex thing for me
character is you do what's right you do
what's right you do the right thing
that's what you do and if you do the
right thing regardless of what the
consequences are that that represents
character and so then how do you build
character it's a beautiful thing because
it's the same thing if you want to build
character you do the right thing you do
the right thing for yourself you do the
right thing for your family you do the
right thing for your the people that you
know you do the right thing for your
community you do the right thing for
your country that's what you do and now
on an individual level
those things are hard things often right
if those are hard things you have to
make the right decisions you have to
live a disciplined life those build
character those little things that you
do on a daily basis to make yourself
better to improve your health to improve
your your situation in life you're doing
those things they're hard to do and when
you do those things they build your
character and ultimately they lead to
your character being a good character as
opposed to a bad one I think this is
really where the value of understanding
what your one word is really helps to
know what your core value is then you
know what the right thing to do is
sometimes you don't know what the right
thing to do is because you have no idea
of a sense of self and until you're
guided by something that you can stand
up to people and say I'm no longer
willing to put up with this because this
is what I stand for I'm not trying to
push you down but this is what I stand
for and this is what I'm going to do
with my life that gives you the courage
the confidence and the boldness to move
forward on it and help you do the right
thing the last rule before the bonuses
number ten is act strategically the big
thing in jiu-jitsu from my perspective
is that you don't go with the strength
against strength right if I don't if I'm
trying to choke you I don't try and
choke you overtly I don't just grab your
neck no I work on your arm and I put
pressure over here and I pass your guard
and then I eventually while you're
thinking about something else
boom that's when I grab your neck or
that's when I grab your arm
and that's what I think on the
battlefield you know you can't you just
don't attack hardened positions of the
enemy and in life you know if you're
trying to be a leader you're trying to
step up and lead somebody you don't just
come down and ark orders at people
because that's not as effective as
maneuvering and adjusting your position
and getting in a better position and
then getting that person to give you
what you want instead of trying to take
it from them
yeah that's a really important lesson
for Parenthood like you can't just tell
kids what to do you know like you just
do it because I told you to do it they
like you I'm gonna be a hooker yeah and
that applies not only to kids hey you're
on a percent applies to kids but it
applies to adults as well and that is
people need to understand why they're
doing what they're doing it and you know
if I want you to go take down some
building and capture some bad guy I
don't go hey hey Joe I want you to take
down this building once your packet
captures bad guy these are the guys I
want you to take with you here's the
route I want you to take in here's the
methodology I want you to use for the
clearance because then when I send you
to go do that mission it's not your
mission it's my mission I came up with a
plan you didn't so you might be you
might have thought there was a better
way to do it or you might had a
different idea of how to get it done
and now when you go out there and you
meet some kind of resistance whether
it's an obstacle you didn't expect or
whether it's some scenario that you
didn't foresee instead of you trying to
overcome it you just blame me you just
look ahead Jocko came up with a stupid
plan and here we are it's failing forget
it we're going back we're not gonna
carry out the mission whereas if I said
hey Joe
here's what I want you to do go figure
out the best way to do it and now you
come up with a plan and now you make up
all the methodology of how you're gonna
get it done and you decide who you're
gonna take with you now it's your plan
you own that plan and when you go out in
the field and you meet a little
resistance guess what you do you say I'm
gonna find a way around it I'm gonna
overcome this I'm gonna overcome that
obstacle to make it happen and that's
another piece of leadership and it's the
exact same thing with kids if you tell
your kid you know you will get good
grades in school that means nothing to
them but if you explain to them hey I
would love for you to get your grades
and here's why it's gonna open
opportunities for you in the future it's
gonna allow you to be able to outsmart
people because you can have more
knowledge than them and then you're
gonna be able to end up making more
money which is actually give you more
freedom in the long run instead of doing
a job that you don't want to do if you
explain all those things to a kid it's
gonna be a lot more successful than just
do what I told you get good grades
because I said so
another great point that can relate
because of my father I see though it
applies to every situation in business
for people to understand the why and for
them to have buy-in and be part of the
plan is super important for your
customers for the people you bring on
your team for your suppliers for your
investors the more core they are to your
business the more they need to
understand the why of what you're doing
they can be a part of it they can spread
the message and the more they need to
have buy-in and create some of the
planning themselves instead of you just
being a dictator saying what to do
so before getting to the bonuses that's
my take on jakka willings top ten rules
to success volume two I would say it's a
tough one rule number one making every
second count is my personal favorite but
there's a lot of great ones in this top
10 I love to know from you guys what do
you think do you agree with me is rule
number one the your favorite the best or
do you have one that you like better
leave it down in the comments below I'm
really curious to figure out what you
have to say if there's someone you like
me to profile in the future top 10 video
we also have a request line check out
the description you can go and cast your
vote I made this video because Michael
Angelo raiko asked me to so if there is
that person you want me to profile make
sure you have your say and finally I
want to give a quick shout out to Oscar
and Dara mo from strategic tech coaching
com thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and doing
the review on your website I really
appreciate it man I'm so glad you
enjoyed the book and thank you again for
your support so thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love see you soon
any type of danger right gives you this
flight-or-fight response so train starts
with training jujitsu boxing Muay Thai
wrestling shooting competing competing
right you get used to those butterflies
when you compete you get those
butterflies and you get used to them and
so train and get used to seeing how that
reaction what that adrenalin feels like
and and also get used to understanding
what the superior action is right
fight or flight because sometimes flight
is the correct response sometimes fight
is the correct response but what you
want to do is you want to be able to
assess and dictate which response you're
gonna give and not just do whatever your
instincts tells you because sometimes
your instinct might be wrong and so
again I don't know what your actually
your the the situation where you're
going into but whatever it is because
people get the fight-or-flight response
to to everyday things to like public
speaking right oh yeah rock climbing and
and that's why I say you know do these
things training them so public speaking
rock climbing you know if you want to
get good at rock panco you're gonna get
over that fight-or-flight response when
you get out go go rock climbing you're
used to it you scared of heights coots
go start parachuting you know you'll get
used to it you're scared of the water
get worked up and go through swimming
and then give come scuba certified just
well the things that you're not
comfortable with get comfortable with
being uncomfortable and while you're
doing - while you're doing them pay
attention you got to detach a little bit
when these things are when you're
training detach a little bit and see
what is going on your mindset see what
red flags that you can see what things
will make you aware of the fact that
your nerves or your adrenaline and your
you feel yourself clenching your fists
you know okay so my fist be aware of it
so that you can change it so you can
adjust it and put yourself again put
yourself into these scenarios and
escalate them so they get harder and
harder harden worse and worse and worse
until your
until you start to get control of these
things this is just a general rule if
you want to lead always be ready to lead
right be ready to step up make sure
you're not stepping on people's toes as
always but be ready to lead and the way
you do that as you think about you what
you do in certain situations you should
always be thinking about that you'd be
thinking even if you were a trooper or a
follower in a certain situation you
should think okay how would I leave what
would I do right now what moves where I
make how what would I do if a
contingency happened right now and what
are the possible contingencies that I
could be looking at what are they and if
you're thinking that as a as a frontline
guy win the opportunity pops up then
just jump on it boom there you go then
when it does happen of course you got to
stay detached because you want to make
sure that you don't leave too far you
don't overstep your bounds and step on
toe so you got to be careful that so you
need to live with that mindset and that
will make you such a a better leader
when the moment does come if you're
always thinking about if you're always
watching like he talked about earlier
I'm watching the leader I'm seeing what
they're doing I'm seeing what I might do
differently I'm still supporting them
I'm supporting you if you're in charge
I'm supporting you but I'm thinking I
might I might do this and then you watch
what would my what would the results of
my decision have been compared to what
they did so you you can be thinking like
leader even though you might not
necessarily be in a leadership position
hmm so live with that mindset that's
what you need to do there's a lot of
people that are eating food and then by
the end of the day your body's in a
crisis yeah yeah body's just processing
all this [ __ ] yeah and people asked
me that too they go you know how much
you sleep first of all I get asked all
the time so I go to bed around 11:00 I
woke up wake up around 4:30 every day so
that's five and a half hours sometimes I
sleep more than that sometimes I go to
bed at 10:00 10:30 11 sometimes I stay
up later but when the person says to me
oh you know I can't do that I feel
horrible how can I feel better and my
first question is like what are you
eating what are you eating because if
you're eating Cheetos and chocolate chip
cookies for lunch there's no way you're
gonna feel good not only if you slept 12
hours a night before and the thing you
ought to do too is when you get done
with work and it was a grind and you
didn't get you eat crappy food and
whatever
happen happened and you got yelled at by
your boss or whatever and the real easy
decision is to be like I'm not gonna go
train tonight those the night you gotta
train cuz that is gonna kick you back on
the track real quick when you get in
there and you see your boys and they're
they're getting ready to tear you up on
the mats and that's gonna get you on
track as opposed to going home and
watching TV which isn't gonna do
anything for you yeah and if there's not
anything whatever the thing is just go
and do it just force yourself to do it
and if you feel like because you ate
lunch then your lunch was you know
filled with [ __ ] well then hey dummy
don't eat lunch tomorrow tomorrow try a
nice salad yeah try a salad with some
salmon and see how you feel then hey I
feel way better today at 6 o'clock duh
yeah now your decision-making will be
better like that people don't understand
how significant it is like all these
little decisions they those are like
that that's the path for the rest of
your existence on earth and if you
decide to go to Cheetos chocolate chip
cookie route you're just making a path
you're carving your path through broken
rocks and glass and there's not the way
to go there's no doubt that the the life
change decision isn't one big decision
that you're making all these little tiny
decisions it's you know having a salad
and set of Cheetos that's that's that's
what it is on a daily basis and if you
think about that and then you just make
the right decision on those little
things that's where that's where the
change is you just raise your standard
[Music]
value not one drop on those self-worth
depends on your it's supposed to mean I
don't ever give up I'd have to be
that are completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top 10 rows a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in the description for
details